The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's do a one minute
review, and then move
onto the Clausius-Clapeyron
equation and see how far we
can go on that.
So, reminding you then, what
you learned last time about
phase transitions is, you drew a
phase diagram in temperature
pressure space here.
And then you had a triple point
somewhere, which was a
unique point.
The triple point temperature,
triple point pressure.
Then there was a gas, solid,
call it coexistence line.
Which kept on going
ad infinitum.
And the a gas liquid
coexistent line.
With a critical point.
So that allowed you
to go around.
You wanted to go from liquid to
gas, you could actually go
around this critical point, and
never actually see a phase
transition.
Then there was a solid liquid
coexistence line.
Which usually has a negative
slope, except for the two most
important substances on Earth,
which are water and silicon.
So for water and silicon,
we have positive slope.
H2O and silicon.
This is why there's
life on Earth.
Did you hear the story of why
there's life on Earth?
This is the secret of life.
Without this, this is
why we're here.
Because of this property.
So, the reason why these slopes
come from the, so I'll
tell you the secret of life.
But first let me remind you what
the coexistence curve is.
dp/dT.
Coexistence is delta S over
delta V, or delta H over T
delta V. And that's the
Clapeyron equation.
Now, the slope of the curves
points us by, look at this
solid liquid line, delta
S, for solid liquid.
I looked at it up here.
It's going to be S liquid
minus S solid.
And you know that's greater than
zero because the entropy
in the liquid state is much
bigger than it is
in the solid state.
You have a crystal, entropy's
very small.
Liquid state, much
more disorder.
Got a positive sign here.
Yes.
Questions?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So, this is
almost everything.
It has this slope here.
Which is a negative slope.
And water has a positive slope.
Right?
Is that wrong?
It's wrong.
Let's go through the argument.
All right.
So, then you have delta V, and
delta V is V solid minus V
liquid, this is per mole.
Now, almost every
substance has V
solid less than V liquid.
So this is negative.
So almost every substance, you
have delta S divided by delta
V is negative.
A negative slope.
You're right.
So I have it backwards.
I do have it backwards.
OK.
See, I was really trying
to make it so that
my drawing was right.
Which is why I inverted the
solid and liquid here.
So I really wanted to
be right, but I
ended up being wrong.
Liquid is less than solid.
Well this is water.
Why do I have it backwards
in my notes.
I've got to correct that.
So this is most substances,
is positive.
OK so, and most substances,
OK?
Except for water and silicon.
Because for water and silicon
this is reversed.
Because the molar volume of
solid for water is bigger than
that for liquid.
So this is bigger than here.
Thank you.
OK.
Thanks for catching it.
OK, so what happens if the molar
volume for the liquid is
bigger than the molar
volume of the solid.
The density of water which is
the inverse of the mole
volume, so the density, the
molar density, is equal to one
over the molar volume.
So you've got the molar density
for liquid is then
smaller than the molar density
for the solid.
It's one over, right?
So that's why ice floats.
Because it's less dense
than liquid water.
So what do you think would
happen in the winter if ice
didn't float, in the
Charles River.
It would go to the bottom.
It would freeze, solid and
you would have no fish.
You would have no life.
It would freeze solid and that
would be the end of life.
And you know, five hundred
million years ago there would
be no fish.
There would be no dinosaurs.
There would be no anything,
there would be no humans.
That's the secret of life.
And the fact that this is also
the case is very useful for
making silicon.
For processing silicon.
Another the secret of life.
Where would we be
without silicon?
Our civilization would be, we'd
still be using stones and
things, right?
OK, so it's super
super important.
Alright, so this is
a Clapeyron story.
Which we ended up
getting right.
Even though I insisted
on getting it wrong.
So what happens now is Mr.
Clausius came around and he
realized that you can make some
approximations that are
very useful.
So the first approximation is,
you can realize that the molar
volume of the gas is always much
bigger than the volume of
the solid or the liquid.
And so as a result whenever you
have these delta V's, for
sublimation, or delta V for
vaporization, which is the
volume the gas minus the
volume of the solid.
Or the volume of the gas minus
the volume of the liquid, you
might as well ignore
the volume of the
liquid or of the solid.
And this can just be equal to
roughly the volume of the gas.
So this is the first
approximation he made.
So now, if you go back to the
to the Clapeyron equation up
here, with this approximation
then dp/dT, the coexistence
line, is delta H divided
by T V gas.
For sublimation.
Or vaporization.
You don't have the delta
V down there any more.
Then the next thing that, next
assumption that he realized
you can make was, well, all
these gases could, they're
like ideal gases.
So we can, instead of having the
volume of the gas here, we
can use the ideal gas law.
This is all, let's do
all this per mole.
So V is equal to RT over p.
You can plug this
back in here.
And then you end up with the
Clausius-Clapeyron equation.
So this is approximation now.
We put in RT over p for here.
We have p delta H, where this
is either sublimation or
vaporization divided by RT
squared. dp/dT, sublimation or
vaporization, and this is the
Clausius-Clapeyron equation.
Two important approximations
that go in here.
And it's not valid for
solids or liquid.
You have to have a gas in there
because of the ideal gas
for the approximation
that goes in here.
And once you have that, you
can integrate both sides.
You've got to put the
temperatures on one side.
Put the pressures on
the other side.
I'll go ahead and cover
this up here.
So you have one over
p dp/dT is equal to
delta H over RT squared.
One over p dp/dT that's
just like d log p.
And that's another form that
you're going to see often for
the Clausius-Clapeyron
approximation is d log p / dT
is equal to delta H
over RT squared.
And I'm freely dropping the
sublimation and the
vaporization because we know
that's what I mean here.
It's only valid for
those two lines.
So that's another form
that you'll see.
And that's not dT here, that's
d log p, d log p dp.
Yeah, that's right,
d log p / dT.
And so now you can take
the dT to the
other side and integrate.
From point one to point two d
log p, is from point one to
point two, delta H over
RT squared dT.
And you make the usual
approximation, which we've
made before.
That delta H is roughly
independent of temperature, or
very slowly changing
with temperature.
And that's fine as long
as you're in a
narrow temperature range.
Which is usually the case
when you have these
Clausius-Clapeyron equation
problems.
So you can take the delta H out
of the integral, the R out
of the integral.
And you can integrate
both sides.
To give you log p2 minus log
p1, is delta H times R,
divided by R, delta H divided by
R. Delta H over R times T2
minus T1 over T1 T2.
It looks a lot like and the
temperature dependence
equilibrium constant.
And in fact, but it's
not, right?
And some people use that
equation here instead of
equilibrium constant.
Temperature dependence.
That's, can give rise
to problems.
Because obviously they're
not the same equation.
But roughly has the same form.
So, another way that you'll also
find this written is very
often p1 and T1 will
be some reference.
Pressures and temperature,
maybe one bar, let's say.
T1, 298 degrees Kelvin.
That's your reference point and
you want to find out the
pressure temperature dependence
in an equation.
So if you rearrange your
equations so p1, T1 are now
some reference point.
They become numbers.
So you have log of a reference
point, T1 here is a number.
So you often see this equation
rewritten then as log p is
equal to delta H over RT.
And I feel like I've got a minus
sign missing somewhere.
Here.
Oh yeah, when you integrate
this, the one over T squared,
there's a minus sign.
Oh, I took care of that by
doing T2 minus T1 here.
I think there's still a minus
sign problem somewhere.
I think there's a minus
sign problem.
Let me check up the
notes here.
Minus one over T1 minus
T2 over T1 T2.
Where's my minus sign?
T2 minus T1.
OK, so I got minus T1,
minus T2 over T1 T2.
T2 minus T1.
This is fine, right.
There's no minus sign problem.
Plus a constant.
OK, so you'll often see
it written like that.
And that gives you a
relationship between the
pressure and the temperature
then, for a substance where
all the reference point
information is contained in
this constant, C. Which
is where the T1's and
the p's come from.
OK, any questions?
We'll do a little example here
of how this could be used.
So let's switch to
an example now.
Let's go to the example, let's
first do the example which is
at the very end of the notes.
So this is an example of RDX.
RDX is a famous explosive,
as I'm sure you know.
And it's plastic explosive.
It's got a melting point
of 204 degrees Celsius.
481 degrees Kelvin.
And it's a problem for, so it's
a very powerful explosive
and you can't see
it in X-rays.
So it's a problem at airports.
You've got be able to find if
somebody's carrying a little
piece of RDX in their luggage.
And so, the question becomes
what do you need to
know to detect it?
You want to find the
vapor pressure.
You've gotta have, and the
machine which basically is
sensitive enough to detect
molecules of RDX that are in
vapor at room temperature.
So the way that you do that
is, you do an experiment.
Where you measure the pressure,
the vapor pressure,
as a function of temperature.
And room temperature, it turns
out if it's not volatile at
all, if the vapor pressure
is very, really tiny.
And so in order to get accurate
numbers, you actually
do your measurements at
significantly higher
temperatures than room
temperature.
They do it close to the melting
point, so you're
actually looking at the
sublimation of RDX.
You do it, let's say, at 400
degrees Kelvin, where the
melting point is at 481
degrees Kelvin.
So slightly below the melting
point you're looking at
sublimation.
And you plot.
Log p versus one over
T. And according to
Clausius-Clapeyron,
that should give
you a straight line.
And in fact, that's exactly what
you see when you take RDX
and do that experiment.
You end up with a bunch
of data points.
That's fall nicely on
this straight line.
And then you can extrapolate
to room temperature.
Somewhere here, let's say,
300 degrees Kelvin.
And find out what log p is,
at 300 degrees Kelvin.
And what you find is that, and
that's the graph that's on the
last page of the lecture notes,
that the vapor pressure
of RDX at room temperature is 10
to the minus 11 bar, That's
ten parts per trillion.
So it tells you that if you
want to detect RDX with a
sniffer machine at the airport,
that machine better
be able to tell you, find one
molecule of RDX out of a tenth
of a trillion other molecules,
basically.
Which is a really hard
thing to do.
So this gives you a
design rule for
these pieces of equipment.
And why they're so expensive.
OK, before we do the next
example, let's see if any
questions on Clausius-Clapeyron.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So, p as some
exponential here?
You know, I don't recall
seeing it as
an exponential form.
But that doesn't mean it's not
used the exponential form.
This is an easy way to do it,
because then you've got a
linear relationship.
And generally we like to
see straight lines.
So this gives you a nice
straight line.
OK, so now let's do a slightly
more complicated example.
Which is, so most of the time
you don't have pure material.
You have a mixture
of some sort.
For instance, if I have a glass
of water on the table at
room temperature.
Above the glass of water, I have
air, there's my H2O here.
And then I've got some air.
Above the glass of water.
And the air's inert
to the water.
It's not reacting
with the water.
So it's like an inert gas
sitting on top of the water.
Then I want to ask the question,
what is the vapor
pressure of the water?
In the presence of this
inert gas, the air.
It's not really the same as the
problem that we've been
looking at up here.
Right?
Because this gas liquid
coexistence line, this
diagram, and this Clapeyron
equation, is all done for a
pure substance.
And at room temperature, at
room temperature, we're
sitting squarely in
the liquid phase.
We're not on the coexistence
line.
At room temperature and
one bar pressure.
So instead of having this system
here, I looked at the
system where I had the water,
H2O, with nothing on top.
With no air on top.
Except the cylinder.
Now, I'd better make the surface
of my water a straight
line, otherwise I'm going
to get in trouble.
There's the water sitting
right here.
And I put a cylinder with
one bar pressure on top.
My cylinder's going to sit
squarely on the stump of the
surface of the water.
This is not going to be any
water vapor at one bar
pressure on that cylinder.
At one bar, we're way up
in the liquid phase.
I would have to decrease the
pressure on that cylinder down
to, I don't know, whatever the
water vapor pressure is at
room temperature here on
this coexistence curve.
0.1 bar or something.
0.05 bar.
Something pretty small.
So that's what we've
been working on.
This pure system.
And now we're going to be
working on this system here,
where we have air.
With a cylinder on
top, one bar.
And we want to know what is the
vapor pressure of H2O in
this system here.
Is it zero?
Anybody want to guess,
if it's zero?
We know there's vapor pressure
there, right?
And a good guess is that that
vapor pressure here, it's
pretty close to the pressure
that you would guess by using
this diagram with
the pure water.
But the key word is,
it's pretty close.
It's not exactly the same.
So, let me ask you this.
Without looking at the notes,
now is p H2O in this problem
here greater than, less than,
or the same as p H2O in the
pure Clapeyron case?
How many people think
that it's the same?
How about smaller than?
Smaller than?
Few people think that
it's smaller than.
How about greater than?
A bunch of people don't
know what to answer.
OK.
I think that if you think about
it, what the difference
is between here and there, you
could probably reason which
way it should go.
Which way the partial pressure
of the water should go under
one bar pressure, room
temperature.
Compared to what you might
expect it to be at room
temperature with a diagram.
So, I'm going to give you a
little bit of time just to
think about it.
Without looking at the notes,
what you think the
right sign is here.
Then we'll do the problem and
then we'll figure out if you
were right or wrong.
OK.
How many people say
it's greater than?
One, two.
Two brave people here.
Two.
How many people say
it's smaller than?
OK.
Smaller than.
So I'm going to say a
large number, OK?
Many.
How many people think
it's equal?
One person thinks it's equal.
Alright, let's do it out now
and see how it comes out.
And then we can reason why it
came out the way it came out.
Logically, without actually
doing math.
Because there's a way to reason
it out that you should
be able to do.
OK, so this is what
we have here.
Then the system is, we
have this container.
Let me redo it instead
of writing air.
So we have the liquid
state here.
Some substance, and it doesn't
have to be water.
That's a liquid, at
some pressure p.
And I'm going to say P capital,
that's going to be
the total pressure.
And the total pressure is given
by the piston here. p
total, p T. And on top here
I'm going to have two
substances.
I'm going to have A,
in the gas phase,
that's the water vapor.
Some partial pressure, p sub
A, temperature T. And I'm
going to have the inert
gas, with some
partial pressure p, inert.
Such that the sum of the partial
pressure of the inert
gas, plus the partial pressure
of A, is the total pressure.
One bar, in our case.
With the water with
the air on top.
And the question, oh, let me
make a few more definitions.
We're going to define p0 as
the vapor pressure of pure
vapor pressure of pure A. So
that's what you would read off
the diagram here.
And what we want, the question
we ask is, what is the partial
pressure of A as a function
of the total pressure?
That's what we're asking.
As I'm increasing the total
pressure, meaning I'm putting
more and more inert
gas in there,
which way is this going?
Is it going up, down,
or staying the same?
And we've got a bunch
of votes up here.
Most people think that it's
going to go down.
Because I put more
gas in there.
OK, I know that if P, capital P,
is equal to pA, then pA is
equal to p0.
Right?
There's no inert gas.
So that's the one extreme
case here.
There's no inert gas, then the
partial pressure's going to be
what you read off
that graph here.
So another way of saying what is
p as a function of capital
P, is to ask the question
what is the slope?
I've got one point here.
If I can integrate the slope
then I have this equation.
So the other way to ask the
question is, what is dpA/dp,
at a constant temperature?
Where I'm keeping the
temperature constant.
And that turns out to be
easier to calculate.
These slopes are always easier
to calculate than
the absolute things.
So we're doing an equilibrium
here.
We have an equilibrium
between the liquid
state and the gas phase.
And we want to know something
about this equilibrium as we
change a parameter.
Equilibrium, what do we always
start with when we have an
equilibrium.
What's the first thing
we think about?
We think about chemical
potential.
Chemical potentials of A, in
the gas phase has to be the
same as the chemical potential
of A in the liquid phase.
Well, I can't think of anything
else to start with.
So let me start with that.
So let's start by writing the
chemical potentials being
equal to each other.
Because we know that's true.
So mu A, in the gas phase,
temperature and with a partial
pressure p sub A. Is equal to
mu A in the liquid phase,
where the pressure on the
liquid is capital P.
What else do we know?
Well, we, what else are
we going to need?
Before we do that, since what
we're after is the derivative,
let's take the derivative
of both sides.
We're looking at a derivative
with respect to pressure here.
Let's take the derivative
outside with pressure and see
what happens.
So let's take the derivative
of this with
respect to total pressure.
Well, this isn't
total pressure.
This is the partial pressure of
A. But it's a function of
the total pressure.
It's a function of the
total pressure.
Partial pressure of A is total
pressure minus p inert.
So, we have to use
the chain rule.
So on this side here, we
have d mu A / dpA.
So I'm taking d/dp
of both sides.
Then by chain rule, dpA/dP.
Constant temperature.
And then on the right-hand
side, I have d mu A / dP,
constant temperature.
Well, d mu / dP, that may or may
not seem familiar to you.
I never remember these things,
but I always remember that
there's, that these
relationships are interesting.
Especially when you're talking
about something like a
chemical potential, which is
really nothing but the Gibbs
free energy.
With respect to pressure, when
we know that the variables
that we use for Gibbs free
energy are pressure and
temperature.
Right?
So this is the variable that
goes with Gibbs free energy.
So this means that they were
taking the derivatives of the
Gibbs free energy with respect
to one of its variables is
something that we should know.
So we go back to writing what
the Gibbs free energy is.
So dG is equal to
V dp minus S dT.
Which is the fundamental
equation
for Gibbs free energy.
And this is the Gibbs free
energy per mole.
That's just the chemical
potential.
The same thing.
And this is the derivative
with respect to pressure.
And this is the derivative with
respect to temperature.
So this thing here
is d mu / dp.
At constant temperature.
It's just the volume.
So now we have this equation,
where we started out with the
chemical potentials.
And we've got these d
mu A / dpA, we've
got d mu A / dP here.
That's just the molar
volume of the gas.
Right, because this is mu
of the gas phase here.
So this is the molar
volume of the gas.
And I have dpa/dP.
And, this is very nice.
Because this is actually
what I'm trying to get.
Trying to see how the partial
pressure of a changes with the
total pressure.
That's what I'm trying
to calculate here.
I know what this is.
This is just an experimental
number.
And then on this side here
I have d mu A / dP.
This is the liquid phase.
Derivative with respect to total
pressure, that's the
molar volume of the liquid.
The liquid.
Great, I'm done. dpA/dP total,
constant pressure, is the
ratio of the molar volume of the
liquid of A divided by the
molar volume of the gas.
What's the sign?
Volumes are positive, right?
This has to be positive.
There's no choice.
It can't even be zero.
It has to be positive, right?
So that means the slope
is a positive slope.
As I increase the total
pressure, p is going to go up.
If I integrate now, this,
starting at, so the total
pressure is equal to pA, I'm
going to get a curve that
looks like this.
OK, if I write on this axis p
inert, so when p inert is
equal to zero, total
pressure is pA.
I'm going to start at p0.
And I'm going to go up from
there, positive slope.
So.
Who was right?
A couple people are right.
So let's think about it
in a different way.
Let's think about it
So we did the math, and we found
that actually it's, and
that turns out to be a
very small amount.
You do a very good job by just
taking this curve here.
And using the pure substance.
In fact, in the notes we have
an example of how much it
changes for mercury.
So for mercury, at 100 degrees
C, for pure mercury, the vapor
pressure is 0.27 bar.
If you add enough inert gas to
make it 1 bar for the total
pressure, you go from
0.27 to 0.2701.
Not much of a change.
They do a really good job
of just picking this.
And if you go to 100 bar, then
you increase it to 0.28.
So it takes a lot of pressure
on top, a lot of extra inert
gas to really make much
of a difference.
But, let's think about
why it would make a
difference, just logically.
So in the absence of this inert
gas here, I just have
the pure substance.
I add some inert gas, what
happens to the entropy on top?
It's increasing, right?
Do systems like to have
more entropy?
Yeah.
So, I have a lot of
inert gas here.
A small amount of A. What if I
had a little bit more A, in
the presence of the inert gas?
Which way would the
entropy go?
It would go up a little
bit more,
you'd have more disorder.
If I have nothing, if I have
no A here, up here and just
the inert gas, then there's
no entropy of mixing.
I add a little bit of inert gas,
there's a little bit more
entropy of mixing.
Eventually, I add more and more,
entropy of mixing goes
up and up and up, and eventually
it comes back down
to where I have pure A on top.
So the entropy of mixing up here
is driving the increase
in the pressure of, in the
partial pressure of A. Entropy
is this amazingly
important term.
That's what we saw.
Entropy of mixing was
responsible for equilibrium.
Without entropy of mixing,
then everything would go
directly to the products.
You'd never have
an equilibrium.
Another secret of life.
So entropy of mixing here is
driving this positive slope.
That's another way of
thinking about it.
And that's why you can guess
ahead of time what the signs
of these things ought to be.
Without doing the math.
Alright, any questions?
OK.
So there's another sample
problem with the notes, which
is sort of like a standard
problem.
Where you're given a
Clausius-Clapeyron equation
for a substance in this form.
So if you look at it, log p is
minus some energy divided by
RT plus some number.
In this case, it's negative,
the delta H is negative for
the substance that
you have there.
And you're given it for the
liquid phase, for the vapor
pressure above the liquid
and the vapor
pressure above the solid.
You can, because the only way
it doesn't work is if you're
looking at solid liquid.
So, and then you're asked to
manipulate this equation to
find different properties.
For instance the triple point.
It's a very common
thing to get, the
triple point from this.
The delta H, it's a way to get
delta H. Just like we saw for
the RDX, right?
The data points formed
a straight line.
And the slope gave you
delta H, for RDX.
Delta H of sublimation
for RDX.
So this is the way that this
equation is used for problems.
I'm not going to do
this problem.
Instead I'm going to
go ahead and forge
ahead to the next topic.
And start it.
This is the topic we're going
to do it after spring break.
And and it really is a topic
that follows this pretty
straightforwardly.
Well, it's more complicated,
but it's similar to this
problem here.
So we saw that in real
life yes, question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The exam.
Oh there's an exam is,
which is, oh I
forgot about the exam.
So let's see.
There's a problem set
that's due today.
The exam will be up to the
problem set that's due today.
Which means that what I talked
about today is not going to be
on the exam.
Because it's not covered
in the problem set.
So let's say it goes up to
Wednesday's lecture.
Which means you might still
have a phase transition
problem, right?
In fact, you're very
likely to get a
phase transition problem.
It's very likely
to be the case.
Because it's an easy problem
to put together.
But you don't have to worry
about Clausius-Clapeyron.
You do have to worry about
Clapeyron, but not
Clausius-Clapeyron, OK?
So, for the exam, we're going to
put on the Web last year's
exam, and you guys are
going to do reviews.
The usual thing.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So that you don't
see the answers.
Yeah, absolutely this
can easily be done.
We'll do that.
Any other questions,
about the exam?
Now, I don't remember.
Is there a problem set that, so
I'm not assigning a problem
set today, right, then?
Right.
OK.
Good.
Because I hadn't loaded
it up yet.
And so now I won't load it up.
OK.
Anything else?
OK, so let me tell you where
we're going to go
then, after the break.
So after the break, we're going
to be starting to talk
about things that are called
colligative properties.
Colligative properties are the
properties like the vapor
pressure, lowering when you have
a mixture in a liquid,
instead of having a pure
substance you have a mixture
of substances here.
And then the vapor
pressure of both
substances above gets lowered.
Anybody want to guess why
they got lowered?
What's the magic word?
Entropy of mixing, right.
Right.
There's more entropy of mixing
if you've got a mixture in the
liquid than if you have
a pure gas up there.
So usually, so let me back up.
Usually it's when you have a
solute, like salt in water.
Where water is volatile
and the salt is not.
Right, a salt in water solution
will have a lower
vapor pressure than a solution
of pure water.
Because of the entropy
of mixing in a
salt and water solution.
The salt and water solution
we have a lowering,
lower melting point.
And that's significantly
lower.
Which is why we use it
on roads, right?
That's a colligative
properties.
Osmotic pressure.
Which you've already sort
of heard about.
Why saltwater fish are unhappy
in fresh water.
That's a colligative property.
So we're going to go through
these colligative properties.
And the mainstay of these
colligative properties is that
we're going to be talking
about mixtures
in the liquid phase.
Here we talked about a mixture
in the gas phase, changing
some property.
From now on, we're going to be
talking about mixtures in the
liquid phase, pretty much.
And so our goal is going to
be able to, is going to be
predict the way that properties
change as you have
these mixtures.
OK. so the standard mixture that
we're going to have, is
to have a binary liquid
gas mixture.
So that means we're going
to have two substances.
A and B. And at first, we're
going to make it
as general as possible.
So we're going to have liquid
phase of A, the liquid phase
of B. So, for instance, this
could be vodka, right?
Water and ethanol.
And water and ethanol
are both volatile.
So we're going to have water and
ethanol in the gas phase.
There, and it's a mixture,
they're perfectly miscible in
the liquid phase, A and B. And
there's going to be some
fraction, molar fraction,
of these things.
We're going to have a molar
fraction in the liquid phase
for A and B. And some molar
fraction in the gas phase, for
A and B. We're going to call it
yA and yB, that's the molar
fraction in the gas phase.
And there's no reason why the
molar fractions in the gas
phrase should be the same as
that in the liquid phase.
And we know that.
We know that ethanol is more
volatile than water.
And so if you have a gas of
vodka, then you can smell the
alcohol because it's
coming out.
But the water is, vapor
pressure is,
very slow, very small.
It's the usual, it's
pretty close to
the usual vapor pressure.
And our question is, what we're
going to be asking is,
how many, if I give you the
total pressure and the
temperature here, what else do I
need to know to find out all
these molar fractions?
So let's first see what all the
variables are that we have.
Usually, we have
two variables.
The temperature and pressure,
and that's enough to tell us
everything.
But here now we have
a mixture.
So we're going to need
more than that.
We're going to need
four variables.
the temperature.
The pressure, and we're going to
need the molar fraction of
A in the liquid phase.
And the molar fraction of
A in the gas phase.
We're not going to need
any more than that.
Actually we're going to
need less than that.
But those are the four variables
that we can easily
identify here.
And we don't need yB and xB,
because the sum of the molar
fraction has to be equal to one.
yB is one minus yA, xB is
one minus xA.
So we don't need y.
So these are a priori the
independent variables that we
have to work with.
Now, we have some constraints
here.
We have a constraint.
Our constraint is that we are
the coexistence point.
There's a coexistence between
the gas phase
and the liquid phase.
And what does it mean for A
liquid to be coexistent with A
in the gas phase?
Chemical potential.
The chemical potential of a
molecule of A in the liquid
phase here is the same as the
chemical potential of
A in the gas phase.
So we have two constraints.
We have mu A for the liquid
phase is equal to mu A for the
gas phase, and mu B for the
liquid phase equal to mu B for
the gas phase.
So we have four variables,
two constraints.
That means that the total
number of independent
variables we have is just two.
It's the number of variables
four, minus the constraints.
OK?
Or you could say six variables
if you include yB and xB, and
four constraints.
Whatever we accounted,
you just have
two degrees of freedom.
So we have two degrees
of freedom.
Which means that if you know the
temperature and pressure,
then you still know
everything.
At the coexistence point.
You still know what the molar
fraction is of your two
substances in both phases.
So that's really powerful.
Or if you know just the molar
fraction of A, and the
temperature, then you know
the pressure above.
And you know everything else.
So in this very complicated
mixture here, you still only
need to know a couple of things
to tell you everything
about this mixture.
And this example here is a
specific example of something
called the Gibbs phase rule.
Which you've seen before.
In this diagram.
In this diagram that
we wrote here.
Where, let me write down what
the Gibbs phase rule is first.
The Gibbs phase rule tells you
the number of independent
variables given a number
of constraints.
So, it tells you that the number
of degrees of freedom,
the number of independent
variables in a mixture, in a
complicated system like this,
is equal to C, which is the
number of components.
So in this case, it would
be two components.
You have A and B. The components
is the number of
independent species that
you have, minus
the number of phases.
So here we have two phases, the
gas phase and the water
phase, plus two.
So for this example here, then
we would have two components,
C equals two.
Two phases liquid and gas.
A and B are the components.
And then plus two.
So two minus two plus two,
F equals to two.
Two degrees of freedom, two
independent variables.
If I'm looking at this diagram
here, in this diagram here I
have C equals one.
One component, right?
If I'm sitting where there's
only one phase, say, the
liquid phase or the gas phase,
then p equals one.
Then F is one minus one plus
two, is equal to two.
Two degrees of freedom.
And so in the pure phase,
I am in a plane.
The pressure and the temperature
are my two degrees
of freedom.
I can freely move around
the plane.
At a coexistence line,
then the number of
phases equals to two.
Then I have one minus two is
minus one, plus two is one.
The degrees of freedom is one.
That's a line.
I have one degree of freedom.
I can move in the line, in
the line in a plane.
Then if I change to the triple
point, where the number of
phases is three, then the number
of degrees of freedom
is one minus three is minus
two, two plus two is zero.
I don't have any degrees
of freedom, I'm
stuck at one point.
So this is an example of the
Gibbs phase rule, specific
where C happens to
be equal to one.
And then, this is a more
generalized example.
So next time, then, what we'll
do is we'll start by deriving
the Gibbs phase rule.
Which is not so hard.
And then start on our way to
the colligative properties.
And then you'll have an exam.